okay so we have another episode of live
software architecture design this is a
design review of quantum computing
capabilities I'm not sure I believe in
quantum computers as real things but we
can certainly simulate what a quantum
computer would do and it's interesting
from a the point of view of
understanding quantum mechanics and
other things and if there are in fact
quantum computing api's that work well
then we should be able to connect to
them okay so we are we've looked at this
several times before but let's walk
through what we actually have here so
here's an example let's remember how
this works
why is my cursor spinning like that that
is not a good sign what is going on here
it's that something to do with let me
just see I'm running this on eleven
point three maybe I should be running in
love and point two um let's go ahead and
do that so here goes um all right so
let's understand what this is so quantum
discrete state zero goes to zero one
wait a minute why is my cursor running
again here something very bad is
happening um this is really odd I think
this is something to do with the chat
tools that I install from our previous
meeting well let's hope for the best
here um okay so can you
- Jacob can you walk through what what
this is actually supposed to be doing
absolutely
so this notebook that you're looking at
contains three more involved just
slightly more involved examples of the
capabilities of the quantum computing
package that we've been developing these
three examples the first one is
deutsches algorithm which is one of the
first things historically that was a
demonstration of quantum supremacy the
ability of quantum computers to do
things using fewer resources ideally
then classical computer let's look at
what this actually says so we've got
quantum discrete state and the idea is
that that is saying this thing that is
named at this wire that is named zero
can be in state zero one is that correct
or the C okay and so let's so I'm saying
you're gonna initialize two wires and
you're going to look at this like the
product of those wires as being your
current state then you take any boolean
function acting on two variables on a
single variable which there are four and
you want to figure out if that boolean
function is balanced or if it's constant
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on let's start off with trying to
understand what this actually is okay
okay so this is a shorthand for entering
a quantum discreet state with a wire
name of one so to speak what do we call
what is what better than the word wire
what are we calling that thing what are
we calling the name thing there we I
think that we decided on quantum entity
okay something is that actually name do
we is now documentation or we just
that's just okay fine so the quantum
entity has two possible states and so
now here where does it record that
quantum entity name in this quantum
discreet state output here so that's
where the one is in the cuter dimensions
one goes to - if you change in your in
the definition over there if you just
change it to W then it W would pop up
yeah okay fine I get it okay very good
okay so this state vector is
representing for that particular by
default the thing is what in equally in
both possible States or what no so the
first one is just in the the lower so
that D 0 is in one state and D 1 is in
another state these are in basis states
in this you know privileged basis that
we're talking about okay but this but
the base is defined by the list 1 0
right exactly and so that this quantum
discreet state corresponds to so how
would I see is there some way of
displaying some aspect of this you know
what what the what the amplitudes are
for different yes so if you do and this
is something that we've been talking
about me and Jose and Savior and Caesar
but we had not decided on what the
cutoff was gonna be we thought that for
states that were small enough and below
some cutoff we would display the state
vector explicitly so if you type in D 1
of 1 comma then in parentheses state
vector well as in parentheses what do
you mean 1 comma and then you meet you
mean in quotes yeah Yanko it's in quotes
do you need to do double double brackets
around what am I doing here just the
first an element of that not not
quotations around 1 so ok like this yeah
okay then just normal okay so I think
this comes from the time in which we
were storing the density matrix right
well it was natural to have sparse
arrays but now for small vectors it's
not so natural to have sparse arrays so
we were wondering whether it would be I
don't think it's necessary to have I
mean it doesn't really matter whether it
look it's an array and whether it's a
sparse array or an explicit dense array
those are sort of equivalent things so
we can perfectly well have the you know
by default we can use dense arrays
unless it's obviously silly okay and
just that you briefly am the right now
you notice here that there's this these
are state vectors now we still have the
capability to do density matrices and in
fact this I've actually coded up and put
into this the ability for the package to
go back and forth between density
matrices and state vectors so when you
when you create a mixed state of state
vectors it automatically turns that into
okay if I say density matrix here what's
it gonna do that's not going to do
anything it doesn't the density matrix
is not an elements of this but it seems
to me so this is a pure State so really
all the information you need to describe
it is the state vector no I understand
that but what I'm what I'm suggesting is
if I if I take d1 and I query it for its
state vector why isn't that just working
I mean why wouldn't that be a reasonable
thing to do that should be a reasonable
thing and I can alright okay so let's do
that but then why don't you also let it
query for a density matrix because if
you think about so if you had something
that was only in a density matrix forms
references in mixed state tends to query
that for a state vector that's fine so
it says missing not it not you know
doesn't exist okay
all right I mean that seems like a
useful thing because it's like it like
what would be the right thing I mean
missing notably Co not applicable you
think that's the right I mean that's a
a quantum philosophy question right what
is the what is the state vector of a
mixed state it's not defined its
ill-defined okay walk me through that I
mean I I know perfectly well what the
quantum mechanics says but I'm trying to
understand not applicable doesn't seem
like the right thing because not
applicable would suggest that there is
something structurally wrong with asking
the question whereas not defined I mean
what it really is is that the mixed
state is not representable by a state
vector right okay so what's the right
way to say that in terms of you know if
you ask for it
it's what is the right term do you get
my question I mean um now if you wanted
to query this for its von Neumann
entropy or first purity you could do
that fine right and it would say it's
it's entropy if it was a pure state it's
entropy would be zero presumably yep
right so okay well anyway so we want to
say let's see what would it be I mean at
the beginning we would say not available
but I don't think that's very good
because it would be nice to be able to
it would be nice to somehow crisply
represent the physics of what's going on
there yeah okay anyway let's put that on
the side for a minute for now we cannot
available okay what's that would you
like to continue with this example or do
you I want to go on with this example
but I'm also I'm also wondering about
the display of quantum discrete state
right now something that we had talked
about me and Jose Xavier and Caesar but
we we hadn't just figured out exactly
what type of description box we wanted
to use and I mean okay all right but
let's let's go through this and if we
have Jeremy do we have Jeremy here yeah
I'm here okay you can
wake up if you weren't already huh okay
um because we're about to get to what
we're trying to represent graphically
here okay so we've got a boolean
function here that is a what isn't that
a boolean function number one of one
variable right yep exactly if I say
something like this it'll do that okay
so now quantum circuit Deutsch comma F
so that just creates its for the quantum
circuit that is just basically this is
the circuit you want to use in order to
figure out if this boolean function is
balanced or constant and that means
basically you want to see if F of 0 is
equal to F of 1 or if they're different
without even knowing what F of 0 and F
of 1 are and in quantum mechanics you
can do that you can open you can with
one call to the function and that you
have F this is part of the design thing
I would like for multi qubit work you
did operations to be one box instead of
multiple boxes on different things so it
would be grateful to do that but this is
one call
can I take this thing whatever it is and
apply it yes I can apply yes so I
applied it to your state was the product
okay so let's just do that so then this
thing here so does this work to just
take this to copy this or does that not
work yet
or is that just a graph yeah I don't
think that works yet okay so do we
understand okay so that that's the thing
that needs to be set up so that that
actually works so the thing is a you
know both input and output form right
okay so that you can pick it up and
actually okay so applying that to this
quantum discrete state we get right
that's some kind of debug print out yes
that was it that is a debug print out
that's fine so it'll ignore that okay so
here I don't really know how to
interpret this I mean okay so this is
two dimensions so this is saying that's
the exact same thing we had before it's
just one is a two has dimension 2 and
yy0
quantum entity zero and quantum entity 1
both have dimension 2 exactly now this
state vector hopefully is something more
exciting than so if I now go here what I
should be able to do is just to say
state vector but for right now I have to
say 1 comma state vector right yeah okay
and then I make that the normal of that
then what I should get now what is that
so that is because you're dealing with
now if you go back to the product stayed
up there D is that it your or D 1 you
would also have something with four
entries because you're looking at the
product of two qubit States and so why
are those indexed why they unraveled why
the indices unraveled like that why is
this not a two by two because when you
describe entangled
right right right it's a single state
vector whose indices are 0 0 0 1 1 0 1
exactly right and so is there any way of
seeing what those indices of the state
fact are so if you do quantum plot
joy Judy or quantum plot of D or maybe
it's might be quantum discrete
okay well that's lovely but I'm gonna
ask for a different thing which is I
think it will be good to have a query of
the quantum discrete state that would
tell you for the state vector what
essentially the labels of each of the
elements of the state vector are okay so
how would those be represented those
those are themselves little product
states is that right yes
those are basis element basis product
state elements so all those elements
themselves quantum discrete states in
other words the label of that guy is
basically a quantum discrete state is
that not correct so you can think of it
that way but we don't want to actually
do that because then we would have a
bunch of these quantum discrete states
with the wire labels and all the other
information
nested within our you know well I mean
but remember that's a query it's a it's
a computation it doesn't have to be
something but it's always there okay
right so the sub value of quantum
discreet state with something like what
would be the right
it could be just basis isn't that right
I mean it's the basis for the state
vector okay yes and this is something
that we had as part of our state
description originally and we decided to
get rid of that so now I think you're
right that this is this is the right way
to do it but so we can query for the
basis why don't we also have a thing
another query which is something like
basis labels and that can be those those
cats and so on
here absolutely you're totally I'm
totally I'm weird right okay so in terms
of how those are actually done would
those be strings effectively of the cats
or what how would we do that actually
what they would be no no what they
should be how do you even do one of
those cats is there a cat yes there is
so if I just say cat of a so then what
this would be is probably because the
zero and one might be all kinds of 1-8
stuff I mean you might have pictures of
smiley faces in there and so on because
the labels the states don't have to be
zeros and ones these
probably the correct thing to do is a
cat of some kind of what would it be a
row box
I mean is it right to put a comma in
there or would it be better to simply
have a thing that looks like this I mean
I would have thought it was more natural
more textbook II to just have that or am
I wrong
oh I didn't even know you can do that
that's great just ask it to come up a
comma B oh we can okay well so the
question is which of those is the better
notation I mean this one is clearer
because if the if the sublevels with 0 0
0 1 then you understand what what
exactly I was going to say that fine
okay then then these are I mean maybe
what we should call this instead of
basis labels we should call it actually
basis cats because they are in fact cats
I don't know whether we mean whether
we're taking cat to actually mean
anything no right now it's just a
representation another possibility would
be to use actual tensor products of cats
right
right right which is okay so look so so
what you've got you've got several
possibilities here so we can either the
basis as explicit quantum discrete
states in which case we might want to
call it basis States which then gives us
a list of quantum discrete states right
and then we might want possibly basis
cats which might be individual cats and
then what you're also proposing what
what is the way of representing me out
at the direct product whether with a
circle x type thing I would say tensor
product we have a disapproved hit what
does it do usually it's it's a form of
outer specializing in symbolic tensors
yeah that's nice
that's nice so then we can have as an
alternative label here so if we call it
basis cats and then the final one would
be actually actually look all of these
makes sense because basis labels in this
case would be simply no getting going on
just something like 0 1 or 0 comma 1 you
go what I'm saying without any because
that's what you want I mean putting the
cat stuff around it is is amusing but
not necessarily um ok so if we say basis
labeled basis cats and basis products
perhaps ok anybody else want to comment
on that as Jose Macy's get product Y ok
fine basis cat products fine ok
all right let's move on so let's go back
now to the visual presentation of both
of these things I mean this thing I
don't like very much what are those so
those are those are various gates right
right so this was just my hack for now
waiting for the design ok all right well
let's go through then what what how do I
get one of those gates so if you just
type in quantum discreet operation and
then you put in quotations why it's not
also complete ok there's a lot of random
functions though I hope we don't need
all of those okay go ahead so if you put
in how to mark and then you put as the
next argument just like W 1 that's it
okay so that is a
of a Hadamard gate operating on quantum
entity of w1 exactly so to actually see
this in operation if I were to apply it
to d0 for example it would say forget it
because d0 is a different
- not the wires they do not overlap with
the input wires for positive right to
generate a message or is it is it should
it just silently do nothing
I'm not sure I don't know it depends on
how things are constructed that's but
let's okay so if I were to do this let's
say I were to create this Hadamard gate
on wire one then if I say d1 here
that are that will apply the Hadamard
gate to that basis state exactly that
was created there and now I mean this
quantum plot which my claim should
actually be the you know basically we
should have
I don't see why quantum discrete state
shouldn't as part of its visual
representation essentially show the
quantum plots it's only reason not to
and no you're right it should but I mean
you want to be able to get all these
pieces out but it's ok to have you know
this this some yeah ok
all right so there may be some other
sort of queries that you want to do here
so one clearly state vector I mean
another query here is well we know about
state vector right we also know about
density matrix I can write out QD s of
density matrix
um and then
I mean we also might as well say you
know as one of the queries here we can
say I don't know whether it something
like pure state Q effectively yeah so
right now I have purity
as one of the things so if you type in
just purity of whatever the state is
it'll give you it'll spit out in a
number and if that number is one then
it's a pure state and I also have the a
query implemented it's a separate
function I think right now I may have
gotten rid of that just to have it
should be all the way at the bottom yeah
yeah and quantum pure state q yeah I
mean this is a decision we have to make
is how many of these subsidiary
functions do we want to have right and
we don't necessarily need that one we I
just thought that it may be redundant to
have to be querying for purity and for
you know pure state q right
um somebody from our livestream Omega
number asks the question is this mostly
reproducing the already existing Manoj
Delgado quantum package where is there
new functionality does anybody know
about that package
don't so I can tell you that that
package did not have the ability to go
back and forth between the state vector
and the density matrix it didn't have
the ability to deal with cued it's um
you know spin the over to systems which
mine like inherently does and it makes
it easy to deal with those mine says
that you know about that package and the
answer is this does more than that
package exactly okay I mean look the the
main thing for those interested I mean
the main thing we're trying to do here
is to make a very nice clean design that
builds on a lot of work that's been done
a lot of work been done by all sorts of
people over the years with quantum
computing and Morton language or
Mathematica exactly this is I mean you
know we are basically trying to do the
kind of the summary job building on
everything that's already been done
exactly and okay on would um alright so
so Jeremy this is this where now we're
talking graphical stuff here so this is
a typical representation of a quantum
see what's what's bugging me you know
for example for a neural net okay let's
just compare what we do for neural nets
okay because I don't think you know well
we're still in play time with quantum
computing this is fine but when it's
beyond play time I don't think this
representation is going to work very
well I mean let's look look at a pretty
simple and remember our goal here is to
make a actually the real thing we really
want is a is a quantum neural net
operating on the etherium blockchain
there we have or then we'd have all
buzzwords hit in a simple object yeah
also CRISPR yeah right right right right
right yes yes CRISPR it meets block
chain meets quantum neural net okay in
any case but but this is you know for
even a fairly small neural net now
admittedly okay this has lots of weights
and things in it but this representation
of a pipeline of operations
is I think a much more plausible as you
there two things I want to understand in
the case of neural nets we have the
concept of a net chain and we have the
concept of a net graph and in the future
we will have the concept of essentially
functional programming constructs
operating on you know that allow you to
have things like variables that are
being used to connect different parts of
the computation what we've got here is
something analogous to net chain I think
my question is there an analog of net
graph now it will have certain
constraints because of reversibility but
is there an analog of net graph or is it
always just kind of daisy chains of
operations right now there is no analog
of net grass in in this system but in in
I mean so what happens here every
quantum entity has certain gates that
operate on it right how do you get
interaction between these quantum
entities you perform you use multi qubit
gates so right now because I just was
hacking my way through the this
illustration this is for instance see X
right there it looks like it's acting on
on the first but it really extends to
the second wire exactly okay but so in
general the way this works is something
can connect two wires that are not
adjacent right exactly and so the way
that that's represented in the
literature is with us like straight
lines going down with circles or X's
connecting them so this is very
analogous to sorting networks which we
have I mean for good reason it's
analogous to sorting networks I mean if
we look up under whether do we have a do
we have those in the data repository yet
I was meaning to make sure those weren't
in the data repository anybody know that
they managed to make it in there
um well anyway let's let's take a look
here
you see here there we go um so those are
sorting networks so those are a visual
representation of something very much
like this right mm-hmm
and it's worth Jeremy seeing how these
things work because this is okay let's
run the sorting Network thing um and
it's actually really interesting that
you bring this up because something that
I was going to talk about Caesar and
Xavier and Jose and I we had been
talking about how and if we wanted to
generalize this to just discrete quantum
mechanics in general and not just
quantum computing and one of the things
that I think may we may want to look
into is generic tensor networks for
quantum states and because a quantum
circuit is just a special case of a
tensor network it's playing offense on
that look to me so a tensor network is a
way to represent different different
tensors and such that you could perform
operations on them very simply so what
kind of tensor I mean this is a tensor
as in a symbolic tensor with a certain
number of legs or what exactly so it has
a certain number of arms a certain
number of legs think it's like a certain
number of covariant a certain number of
contravariant indices come and perform
contractions you can perform what does
that have to do with quantum mechanics I
mean there's a whole formalism I mean
like Roger Penrose had this whole
formalism exactly so a quantum circuit
is is merely a specific instance of a
tensor Network where all the gates are
tensors and these wires are performing
contractions of them in essence okay
Jose do you want to make a a any helpful
comment about this and I'm not sure I
can I can imagine that that this is
referring to matrices mainly and they
and the operators being represented as
matrices
well so for example we have here I just
pulled up a paper here quantum tenser
networks in a nutshell oh yeah I've seen
this this so this is and these are very
useful for lots of things in condensed
matter physics and high-energy physics
nowadays but I again this is not
something that I'm attached to but I was
wondering if this is something it's
obviously makes some sense to do this
especially I mean the in general I don't
understand these pictures do you
understand these pictures I actually
read through a bunch of this the other
day this exact paper so basically just
it's showing you the type of things the
diagram denotes like how what type of
things are equivalent to what other
things okay so for example these are
successively alighted forms
let me just capture this picture for
example those are um see those are
successively elided forms of some kind
of way of representing these networks is
that correct mm-hmm so if we're going to
represent these things I mean because
because my point is you know well you
just have a toy Network that's just for
examples you know where you've got three
operations or something this is gonna
work fine but when you have something
more serious which who knows maybe you
know in the next you know maybe nobody
will ever implement but but your point
is that also for purely theoretical
purposes these representations of things
I mean you know my point about this
whole system is that you know this whole
quantum computing system is that whether
or not quantum computers get built it's
still a useful formalism for all kinds
purposes and you're supporting that by
the discussion of this so this is so
here okay so these are some states for
which we have reasonable representations
like this GHz States exactly so we
obviously need to understand this so
explain to me oh my gosh what is all
this stuff
okay how about you start at the
beginning here and just explain to me
what this is well so this is this was
only one of the things that I was trying
to discuss and there's a ton of other
things okay but I think this is gonna be
important in okay what we're gonna get
will I think this is going to be
important and understanding you know
what the graphical representation of any
of these things is okay um in fact I
don't really see how we can get away
without that in one sense so just
explain to me the covariant and
contravariant index idea you know is
that is that is co-parenting
contravariant indices did that relate to
spin 1/2 or is that not the fact that
there are two indices explain to me what
what um you know what does cover and a
contravariant mean in this context so
it's like a vector and a dual vector I
understand what it means in the usual
general relativity manifolds yeah
context okay what does it mean in the
case of a quantum in this quantum case
in the quantum case the coherent and
contravariant indices don't mean much
except for the fact that these things
end up being matrices like these you
know like d by d type things instead of
just D elements as your quantum gates
but so is that is what you're saying
that the fact that you're using two
indices to represent the thing is that I
don't understand is that something my
impression here is that these matrices
used here are always of the type one
index at one index down and these
introduces are restrictions such that
you have to always contract the one
index up and one index down exactly so
somehow do you have to be very careful
not to transpose the operators because
you would end up contracting the wrong
indices right but is that one index up
one index down is that something that is
representing what is the current what is
the correspondence between this wires
representation so here we appear to have
something which appears to be applying
so these appear to be different quantum
entities so to speak and this appears to
be applying operations I don't
what that plus operation is those what's
that if you control not operation okay
fine
so it's applying those operations three
times and that's that representation so
that will be something similar to the
representation that we have here right
exactly and then this is some kind of a
lighted form of that representation um
somebody is saying yeah somebody is
saying that they would appreciate it if
we supported this first form here yeah
we agree we're going to have a form like
this um the the question is when things
get more complicated what do we do
and I don't completely understand so
this here where you've got these
successive operations all appearing to
occur at the same time it's kind of
funky mm-hmm and I'm not sure at this
point what the right thing to do is okay
well let's let's just take a look I mean
okay so but in what sense in what sense
does a tensor network generalize a
circuit what is more general about a
tensor network than a circuit so in a
tensor network in general you're not
just dealing with things that have one
upper and one lower index you're dealing
with you know things that have you know
K upper and lower indices what's the
difference between that and a gate that
just takes a random you know it doesn't
just take in in general what you're
saying is you can have something which
takes you know K inputs and produces M
outputs which is which can be
represented by a tensor and your
formalism with a certain number of Cobra
and certain number of contravariant
indices mm-hmm so these in general these
multi or more than two index tensors um
in networks are very useful for
representing many-body quantum physics
um for instance if you look at like this
paper even talks about the PEP s these
um entangled product states and for
those types of things you need much more
complicated tensor networks in order to
describe the physics that's going on but
that's actually the most compact way to
describe the physics that's going on
okay well that's interesting but but
okay but so for our purposes the way we
should think about it is that those
things are going to be operations that
don't just span that don't just pick up
two things here but might pick up three
things and produce three things as
output and so on I mean in the quantum
in the in the standard quantum pure
state business you're going to always
have same number of inputs and outputs
am i correct exactly okay so looking at
this diagram here Jeremy what's
happening here so the color which I
don't consider very good here is
attempting to represent what what
persists to what
so to speak making sense so like that
that wire connects to there and then it
does an operation and then it's
different so to speak okay it's a little
different note those vertical columns
just mean make a swap yeah that's
correct but what these things here mean
is do an operation where you take two
bits in and you produce two bits out
it's directional or the output okay well
what happens is this is a function which
takes two inputs and produces two
outputs okay example controlled-not
okay so you can think of this
significant about the open plus circle
if it it's just a it's just a
traditional notation for that particular
kind of gate and and how many such gates
are there and what are their what are
their representations I mean do all like
like you know for example in boolean
algebra you know we have things like the
NAND operation which is you know which
we kind of decided to represent using
this sum this slightly funky there you
know thing yeah so you're very limited
in the number of such things that you
can use and
quantum computing because all operations
have to be reversible so really you have
things like this not operation which the
control is the line coming down from the
dot and then the knot is the circle with
the the lines through these a two
variable two input two output things if
they're a composite constructor which
are considerably more complicated on
their so they're in general they're not
that many more complicated things if you
stick to the traditional fault tolerant
gates you have things like a swap
operation which is used it is
represented by like an two x's one on
each of the wires and a line connecting
them so how traditional have these
representations become and what um so if
I look up like quantum gate icons yeah
go for it you'll see pretty much the
same things everywhere if I look that up
this is what I get for quantum gate
icons that didn't work very well I don't
know what quantum circuits or quantum
circuit quantum gate is probably star
gate or something um quantum circuit
diagrams okay here we go these are more
more reasonable so the the thing at the
end there and most of those is the
measurement and that's how you that's
like the general measurement
representation the two lines that are
like very close together that means a
classical operation which my thing I
actually have but I don't have a way of
visualizing that right now X and Z are
the powell the operations agent Hadamard
the line going down from that is again a
control not alright so there's there's
some reasonable commonality there's not
that many
okay okay fair enough so we probably
should actually just use these
traditional notations right I personally
think the non italic look better but but
that's just a detail um somebody on
swish car on on twitch is saying there
was a paper recently making connections
between geometries of quantum circuits
and neural nets if you can tell us the
reference we'd be interested to see it
I'd be interested to see it um you
easily maybe you know Jacob do you know
what that paper is don't ask why I don't
I would love to see it
okay so whoever swish car is if you if
you're hearing this do send us a link to
it thank you the
um let's see so so back to this so it
sounds like I mean let me just capture
an example here um you know it sounds
like we should be trying to make
graphics that pretty much look something
like this
mm-hmm that seems like it's become
conventional enough that that's what we
should do
exactly um fair enough
so okay so do you have do you have what
you need to be able to start doing that
I mean these these don't seem to me like
they need a heck of a lot of graphic
design I mean Jeremy do you want to
comment on this it's not anything I mean
the only thing I find a little weird
about this is the the fact that the
horizontal quantum entity representation
is no different from the representation
of these vertical things that seems kind
of goofy to me mm-hmm
I mean maybe we can have a way of
differentiating them but one that could
be gray for example thicker and gray or
something like this for example these
quantum the problem is that because
these things are these sort of
attachment points are just I don't
understand what is this one here that
this is a compelling that you has a
control control not operation which is
at awfully really okay so there's not
that many different representations
there's not that many different graphics
we need for this because it's the same
couple of gates that you're using over
and over again okay and what are these
things here so V is square root X it
says it's the root of a poly X matrix
and why is it called V that's just what
it's called what is it and German or
something like like PD you know s PDF or
something good I couldn't tell you okay
all right I think I look it up okay
all right but okay so
if we think we're just gonna have
quantum circuits simply display as one
of these traditional diagrams that's
then the story of that we don't yet know
what we're gonna have a state just by us
is there any conventional way to display
a state not particularly when you're
dealing with you know when you can be
has pure states and mixed I'm sorry I
want to make another comment this
representation here of the name of the
quantum entity is the interval to label
the name of the quantum an entity right
so that's what I have the hack of if you
look at this circuit right above that
yeah what does that mean zero a super
that it's just I was labeling the wire
as like wire a which were initializing
as being in the zero quantum state but
what are these are these the
initializers here yeah I see so there's
two different things here there's the
label of what the wire is so it might
say a off on the left here and then
there's the initializer yeah right and
the fact that they've chosen not to show
all the initializers at the beginning is
probably cutesy but perhaps unnecessary
sure is that do you agree with that
statement I mean yes I agree with that
statement okay um so okay so then what
we expect is that we'll have you know an
initializer this triangle seems like a
pretty decent representation of that we
should check whether there are others um
then but with the label you know with
the name of the thing right at the
beginning here right mm-hmm I don't know
whether we need a colon or something
after the name followed by all this
stuff we need a convention for how to
represent Jeremy do you have any great
ideas you understand what's going on
here these quantum entities are just you
know I mean in a ok deep inside a modern
quantum computer what might one of these
entities be it might be an atom or
something
and this is so this is the kind of the
world line of an atom so to speak here
and then this thing here represents the
interaction between two atoms according
to this you know this operation the
ration is how do we want to represent
and again the analog in the in the
sorting Network the thing that's
interesting about I mean if you look at
this diagram here one of the things
that's kind of yucky about it in my view
is it's kind of hard to see how long
well I mean if you start looking at it
you can see how long that wire survived
without operations
honestly this color thing didn't work
very well here and maybe that's not you
know an important thing to capture I
mean how long are the longest of quantum
operations that people talk about right
now how long are the longest diagrams
that people seriously use there are very
long diagrams that extend to multiple
lines um so I don't know what we want to
do in that case you can figure out I'm
glad you met so I had not I mean none of
the examples that I've shown here
actually span that much distance so
wanna sue there you know it's better
it's easier to go down the page and
across the page but the traditional
representation of quantum no I
understand that we can certainly have an
option to draw the diagram down the page
I mean or do people usually just go you
know line by line chopping it up they go
line by line like reading sheet music I
see um okay
the paper the geometry of deep learning
okay why is this relevant
you
you
okay I mean these are the these are
diagrams that we have decided not to use
for neural networks although maybe this
is a more elegant I mean you know a lot
of papers have these kinds of diagrams
although it seemed to be going out of
fashion because people are having you
know because the things are getting a
bit too complicated so I don't
understand the relevance of this what is
what is I mean this is all stuff about
traditional neuron that
this is interesting actually this is
interesting
hmm well I don't I don't completely
understand I don't understand the
relevance of this to the quantum case
I'll have to look into it okay but let's
just dumb I mean just curious here yes I
mean this is really just this is
something we already have I mean we
already have the graph in neural nets we
can extract the graph of the neural net
um and what's interesting here I suppose
is that this is the kind of
representation I mean look what we're
seeing in the neural net case with
something like this that is the stacked
version of something very much like what
you're talking about here because this
is a bunch of tensors basically they
don't happen to have yeah it's a bunch
of tensors um that bunch of tensor
operations stacked up and they're making
sense whereas your um and what you've
got are a bunch of it's the same thing
um humph
okay well there's something to
understand there I think we can make
something very nice in general but in
terms of having it break multiple lines
you know if we build the right
typesetting constructs it will just
break I I think we can make it how would
we do that um I'm pretty sure does
anybody want to comment on that Jose do
you happen to know I mean we need a
different set of people to really
address that properly but if we wanted
to have the question is if we broke this
in terms of the actual now it's it's
gonna be complicated right but it's
gonna have to have a doesn't it have to
have a multi-line function gosh I
haven't thought about the road might
would a row work perhaps you show the
beginning and the rest on clothing no no
that seems that seems it's really funky
the let me see I think that's I don't
think that's good I mean let's let's try
to understand okay so you're saying
Jeremy just row well let's just try row
of table of X comma 200
[Music]
okay so that just worked I mean the
trick is if things change height you
know you get well I would this ever
expand an umber of lines or that no I
think but I think the real problem is
that you really want to have well so I
mean it's little indent but the real
thing is you might well maybe you don't
care you might want to have something
which attaches you know where you can
label the end and label the beginning
again so to speak I mean naively what
what you're doing here one of the
problems here though is that this is
basically a bunch of graphics but I
suppose what you're effectively doing is
if if we said what could we do we tell
me just to make an eye even thing we
could just make I just want to make a
sample of this for one second let me
just do as this as possible
if we do a graphics road as a graphics
row does do you know if a graphics row
will them so let's say we make a
graphics row of table of graphics of
disk for example how somebody should
adjust the microphone enough
that did not work well because that
obviously doesn't
okay so row of that
okay so let's just look here
that's an interesting issue we either
get to have um so let's say image size
to 40 or something okay so that works
fine and even bizarrely indents a bit so
what we would do be doing here is we'd
be saying something like graphics of
table of I mean I'm just gonna make a
naive case because I want to see what it
works here um line um so let's say line
from
what am I trying to do I'm trying to
make several lines stacked on top of
each other so I want the x coordinate
zero y coordinate y 1y table that y 0
for for example and then that will make
that and then I want to say that thing
image size
goes to let's say 50 okay let's say I
sure that same exercise goes to 30 and
now my idea would be to take those guys
and say make a table of those guys let's
say 50 of them um yeah let's just take
this and then then I can say row of that
and see what it does
okay this is looking promising so now
the only issue is that those have gaps
between them and the question is how do
we get rid of the gaps right so this is
doing the right thing Jacob you can see
what right yeah um so the only issue is
how do we get rid of the gaps and I'm
guessing that there's an option in row
to determine that or maybe oh it might
be a graphics padding issue
um it's probably a graphics padding
issue there's probably a way to specify
in graphics they want zero padding um
yeah image padding who knows there's
some detail there um but I think this is
gonna work so if we do it this way now
the only problem is that the selection
then it's gonna have a very weird
selection behavior am I making sense but
this will be the automatic
representation oh I would think so
because ya can get quite large I was
wondering whether we have some sort of a
scrolling bar it's a window with a
scrolling bar and it allows you to see
if it's too large you can move it
horizontally yes well we could do that I
mean that will happen naturally if
somebody needs to adjust the microphone
we're hearing a bunch background noise
the um
background noise please adjust something
um okay well okay fine so we could try
okay look maybe what we could try doing
is assembling this as graphics objects
and then if we end up splitting it apart
and having them be in a row then so be
it but otherwise we could just have it
go off the page I suppose the only
problem is I think the graphics will
naturally resize it okay so long as the
you know so long as the image size is
adjusted so that it has a certain you
know because otherwise it's going to
adjust itself to just squash in to fit
the width you get what I'm saying yeah
um and there may be some other tricky
things like those fonts may have to be
adjusted with their font size to be
dependent on the graphics size and so on
if we want to use those fonts as
essentially visual you know indicators
rather than as actual letters of a
certain size right that make sense
okay um so we still would be nice to
have some ideas here all right but let's
talk about the state representation so
you're saying that I mean your version
of the state representation right now is
essentially this quantum plot the
quantum plot is a way of showing the
states is it not right and wieldy when
you have large states yes I mean does
anybody care about about a visual
representation for large states well I
mean it is nice to be able to see where
the you know where the amplitude is
concentrated um but maybe there's a
different way to do that that doesn't
involve you know essentially making a
histogram certainly with a with a you
know binary product state for example
you could imagine an array plot but with
a you know if you have a six-way product
state that's not gonna work right okay
so let's so we don't know how we're
going to represent quantum discreet
state although yeah I mean you know to
me one of the most one of the naive
things would be what is the what is the
the basis state with the most amplitude
in it I mean a lot of times in practice
that's what people are going to care
about
in other words essentially the ranked
list of most popular you know basis
state follow going onward I mean like if
you Turing chemistry or something that's
probably what you care about okay what
is the thing usually you know now you
know in some cases the thing may be very
widely
you know widely distributed but another
case is going to be heavily concentrated
we are listening to somebody typing
could you please adjust um okay we
better go on and take a look through
some of these other things here but but
I think I mean and by the way I think
what you've done here Jacob of having a
gray background is a reasonable idea I
mean we need some characteristic
background color I mean it we good to
have some spooky quantum color for this
like light purple or something I don't
know it just just in order to phim it in
some way so it doesn't look like um and
I think what we're gonna end up with I
mean it would be interesting it is
surprisingly complicated to draw this
diagram for the for the sorting Network
it will be very cool if the same yeah
maybe it doesn't make sense I'm just
wondering whether there's this thing
where would could basically use the same
graphics sort of technology if there's a
way of representing I mean this thing
okay how do we represent if we were
going to represent a sorting Network
which by the way is presumably a valid I
mean is is there a valid quantum
operation that corresponds to entered
it's the swap operation isn't it mm-hmm
so how do you draw a swap operation so I
think I was saying earlier you can draw
just X's connecting the two wires with a
like a line between them or you could
just draw three C nots okay wait a
second what wit with three C nots
where's the third one in the middle so
you could have C not acting on like from
the first going down to the second and
then C not from the second going up to
the first and then IC not going from the
first down to the second that's
equivalent to a swap operation but if
you want to have a representation for
the swap on its own then that's just in
X on the first one and X in the second
one and a line connecting them okay fine
so it's just this thing with a bunch of
X's at the ends right by the way
somebody named tangled spaces from the
live stream has is asking the question
what about phase and they're right the
thing I was saying about what thing has
the largest amplitude is kind of I mean
that that's that's not telling us
anything about the phase and in fact
this diagram is not telling us something
about the phase either is it right so in
the beginning we had talked about some
way to do that some way to
it's complex amplitudes and phases but
we hadn't really ended up concluding
anything well okay so here's a naive
idea okay that might be in trip
you know perhaps there's other people
who thought about this but you know one
naive idea would be to draw essentially
a polar diagram in which okay so here's
a crazy idea for you okay so so let's
let's see this is this is circuits this
is graphics of circuits and now we also
have graphics of states um okay crazy
idea is draw a polar diagram where every
state every basis state is a point in
the polar diagram and is labeled with
its name so let's draw a let's see list
polar plot it's basically what we're
doing and the list polar plot would have
I don't even remember how this works is
it R theta presumably it's R theta so
will be a random real ten random real
zero to two pi right and I want to do um
let's make a bunch of those um can we
join them to the origin do you think
anybody no magnificent but what happens
if we say is there a way of joining
these to the origin that's probably
gonna join them each to themselves yes
okay so that maybe is uh um so the
problem is if they all have the exact
same phase namely zero phase or
something like that then they're all
gonna overlap but they're not if they
have different amplitudes they all have
the same amplitude you're right if they
all have the same amplitude and phase
then you're toast donate in by the way
let me just see is there a way of
joining
does anybody know can somebody look this
up is there a way of joining these to
the origin
whole axis origin it's kind of silly
actually we should have that um the
Sushma here
yes um you could you make that
suggestion Brett yes sir I don't I mean
unless we have it and I just don't yeah
I am looking at the documentation but if
I don't find anything I will let him
know okay um okay but in any case why
proposal here so we can do this in what
is the thing polar to rectangular what
is that from polar coordinates good okay
so from polar coordinates of this thing
let's say so what I'm proposing is just
to be explicit here um actually let me
do this like this I want the line from
zero to so let's say we make a gray line
from zero to that and then we make a
black piece of text at and let's say I
don't know who knows what it is yet
random I'd say random integer 1 3 and
then I want that at position at the same
position as the other thing PP um so
then this is si am I getting was wrong
I'm not sure they're lying construction
is correct then you have to map to have
different
no I'm going to do that because I'm
going to make this whole thing is gonna
be a table and then the whole thing is
going to be graphics what am I doing
wrong here valuation points oh oh
polar coordinates from polar coordinates
is R comma theta what am I doing wrong
here R theta
yes what is wrong there how can it say
five point six nine how could there be a
five point six nine in a thing that says
that wait wait five point six nine is
not smaller than 2pi yeah it is I mean
it is I'm sorry it's smaller than two pi
so what is it complaining about it's not
a valid set of spherical or hyper
spherical points okay hold on what is
going on here that we say from total
coordinates okay I am totally confused
what is wrong with that
oh wait a minute - pie - pie that's kind
of stupid why does it do that ah yes yes
stupid is there a good reason for that
is it just dumb no I remember discussing
this whether we should allow any angle
and different if we're not allowing any
angle the very least message here that
should not be as obscure as this it
should actually say is not in the range
minus PI to PI can we who is this I
function yes could we complain to him
please yes I would
okay okay this is not totally stupid
what this did here do you agree I mean
it's a little yeah go ahead
no I I think that I like the idea I
think that there's some refining that
needs to be done right but I mean so
this is then showing the amplitude and
phase and if they were all on the real
line you would basically see something
which just had the ranking of you know
which just had each one of these it
would say you know 0 0 0 0 1 0 etc
etcetera etcetera ranked on the real
line my making sense
even in this picture some of the cats
are so close to each other that day you
can't see one from the other correct but
that's life I mean you know there's no
there's no way there's no way we're
gonna be able to have this be perfect
the issue is I mean I don't know I
haven't seen I mean you know what do
people do in representing quantum states
yeah I understand but that's but how do
you represent phrase there
we know that there are faces right but
what are you doing the phases with color
coding the argument of the complex
number with the color code or something
well tentatively I consider this not
totally stupid and and maybe we can have
multiple I mean yes okay I mean I don't
know what this does for a density matrix
though this doesn't really generalize to
a density matrix does it no I mean it's
sounding to me like we're gonna wind up
needing multiple representations of this
and okay this one is one possible thing
but I really and I think it'll be a
useful one to at least have code to
support this just so we can play around
with and see whether it's reasonable
okay
in the - 15 minutes that we have and an
Eric um should push back the next thing
by another 15 minutes because in fact
I'm gonna be able to go past I'm gonna
be able to go 30 minutes late on this
next meeting okay okay so let's let's
look at your other things here so the
quantum half adder
okay that's dandy again so what is the
difference in a quantum operation and
this quantum discrete state first
argument remind me of that so we decided
we had a whole like hour-long discussion
about this how you can either have the
regular state arguments like we have in
the first three examples right there or
you could have product or the trace or
alright because these are essentially
making out of products of things that
they're combining sort of subspaces to
make the whole thing it's non right the
Combinator's
what are you saying are they
combinations would mean well in a in the
anyway nevermind doesn't matter but okay
there did you mean that in a useful
technical sense now okay fine um sorry
but you might have been meaning
something very interesting with which I
didn't understand but okay fine
um because I don't know any relationship
between Combinator's and all this stuff
um okay so it is a way of essentially
okay fine that all makes sense okay so
here quantum discreet operation applying
so let me ask this question in the
neural net framework these are
represented by net ports in various ways
I think I think the analog of the
quantum entity here is a net port you
know anything about the now that is not
necessarily a very helpful statement but
let's take a look here um okay I so that
is a oh my gosh okay um now that's not
particularly useful so it's a labeling
of I mean essentially it's a way of
labeling input and output that are
supposed to connect to each other it is
it is the direct analog of net port but
it does not appear to be syntactically
similar to net board I think that the
difference is that you can't have
different input and outputs in the
quantum case what do you mean by
different oh oh you mean I see that
every every port has to be both an input
port and an output port exactly yeah
you're right you're right so that does
make it somewhat different okay and
actually these this these gate
constructed since that I have right here
remember before we had the whole wire
goes to the dimension and
all that crazy stuff you know that's all
out of there I still have the capability
of doing that for instance if you wanted
to put in like the quantum discreet
operation of how the ex gate on some
wire one and then you wanted to say
cutit dimension goes to five then it
would generate the how the X operator in
like a first bin five over two system
okay and you could even do power goes to
three so then it would do you know the
like the three poly X operations
consecutively in that you know five
dimensional space
wait what what where's the power goes to
three thing going so if you it's it's an
optional it's an option for Walt so if
you say quantum discreet operation yo
and then you put pally X gate yeah okay
hold on hold on so you say quantum
discreet operation
you
you
okay and then your first argument is
probably xscape probably great like that
mm-hmm
and then your second one is the wire by
the way we can't call one thing Toph
away even though my friend Tom TOEFL II
you know we cut and then we call this
poly X gate we have ever gotta call it
toughly gate okay I can continue what
what should we do should we call it poly
X so should we call it poly X gate is
another thing that isn't a gate that's
the first argument of a quantum discreet
operation there are gates but I was
saying poly X earlier you wanted me to
put gate because you thought that it
could be misconstrued the use in a non
quantum computing context yes fair
enough then we should we should forget
for everything you know a fix gate to my
friend Tom totally and so if you put
wire but like W right there and then
after that you just put in quotations to
the dimension and then an arrow
v yep and then you wanted to say in yeah
so that creates something that is a poly
X operator in this five dimensional
space so acting on 504 two systems nope
so judges have options for that and
power which is way simpler than the
previous construction fine but if I
apply this to a spin half system it's
just gonna complain or what you can try
it okay so the way I would do that eyes
I would say apply that how do I apply
one of these operations you just put the
quantum state in your square brackets
after that operation but you need to be
acting on the same qubit so if you put
that on okay let's blow this to qubit
one and that's do this and then say d1
here so what it does is my framework it
when you act on so
immediately when you acted on a quantum
state it'll correct the dimension to the
dimension of that wire in your state if
necessary it just does that silently yep
I can put any message to that no but is
it the right thing to do or not I don't
really understand what that is I mean in
other words if I've got a spin five half
system and I operate on it no I have a
spin five halves
operator which happens to only have a
poor little electron to operate on what
is it I don't really understand how that
works so the point is that it doesn't
work but that right now I'm like
automatically correcting for that and I
guess I should spit out an error message
that says you should have some message
okay um okay let's look quickly through
these other things right now so the half
adder just shows that you can you know
take quantum superpositions and do what
you know classical half adder does with
them and then quantum teleportation is
quantum partial trace so I think I've
shown that one before
and that's actually there's there's a
way to do that in the quantum discreet
state you can trace out subsystems like
that but basically you take a quantum
state that has you know and sub States
in it and I want to get rid of these
ones so just throw it on so I wonder
whether I mean depending on whether we
want to have so many functions or
whether we want to just have quantum
discrete state and then something like
projection arrow something like this
another possibility okay I don't know if
that's the right way to do it I mean
that would be but is that equivalent it
is purely what you're doing is simply
projecting into that subspace is that
not correct yeah that's great so I mean
what we would naively do is we would do
that and then we would say state vector
for example and that will be equivalent
to what you have down below which seems
pretty reasonable actually mm-hmm like
this that definitely seems reasonable
okay um okay
what is the difference the quantum
circuit here is yet different so quantum
circuit is a combination is a sequence
of quantum discreet operation light and
there's also the ability to I think we
bit over this before as well you can
actually simplify the quantum circuit
there's different arguments you can have
that perform different simplifications
to get rid of like algebraic identities
and things like that but we probably
don't have time to go into that again
right now okay all right okay quantum
teleportation so this is the most
interesting example here so basically
you have these two people they each
start out with States the interesting
one is Alice she has this non-trivial
state is interesting just because it's
not a name I've usually seen used in
these yeah and so in quantum computing
in Cilla's are that's like the way you
talk about these extra bits computations
okay fine people naming their children
that yet who knows right okay but bob
has this trivial basis state and Alice
has a state this instance the position
and Bob wants Bob and Alice want to
transport allison state to bob you know
in this quantum fashion so alice could
really have whatever state she wants and
do this yeah okay basically this quantum
circuit is this is just a demonstration
that here you can deterministically
using classical information after the
quantum circuit like included in the
quantum circuit transfer a quantum state
with unknown amplitude and phase okay so
we able to show that symbolically is a
quantum circuit here what is this
quantum discreet conditional operation
what is that so that's something that
based on the outcome of a measurement it
performs certain quantum operations
okay and where is the measurement here
is that where's the measurement
happening in this in this quantum
circuit is the measurement being
represented or
yep the measurement is the end
measurement oh it's really horrifying
business okay
yeah but you need the classical
operations you saw the the double wires
in those diagrams we're looking at
online you can't really do quantum
computing without them by the way what
on earth is that error message I have
not seen that no I'm sure you haven't I
mean this is this is what's causing
these weird things that I've just been
reporting can somebody ask Roger to take
a look at this this is obviously the
thing that's been messing up my
installations for the last day or so and
it probably has to do with um it
probably has to do with installing some
weird experimental thing um okay okay
explain to me so the interesting part
here is that the laws of quantum
mechanics tell you that you cannot copy
a quantum state so you can't just create
a copy of Alice's State and give that to
Bob as well so what's happening here is
you're using these reversible quantum
operations in conjunction with
measurements and classical operations
conditioned on those measurements to
deterministic lis transport Alice's
state to Bob yep and no matter what the
operations are you get out I mean the
the result is of your quantum
measurement you can always act with the
specific classical operation on that
that'll give you exactly what the
quantum state was not even knowing what
it was no I I know this I know this
claim right so so walk me through a
couple of things here so first of all
can we verify this symbolically or are
we only in other words if I put symbolic
variables in here what will I get
reasonable results so will I know the
symbolic variables work through
everything up until the measurement
because for measurements you need
specific probabilities you can't really
do a measurement on symbolic amplitudes
let's think about that even in our
framework for representing probabilities
symbolically
so maybe there is a way to do it but I
could not think of an easy way to do it
so and everything else in the circuit
should work symbolically well that's
great but let's let's try and nail this
particular thing so what you're saying
is that you are trying to yeah this
really should work using our symbolic
probability stuff so I mean in other
words there's this notion of probability
and what you're saying is you're slicing
off pieces of this you know with certain
probabilities you're doing this with
your doing okay so in this case here
you're saying if this thing is equal to
that then give this etcetera if I'm not
mistaken right okay so I think you can
do that with I think you can do that
with this probability function in other
words because it has it has some kind of
conditioned there's a mechanism for
conditioning this on that and so on I
will definitely look into that okay but
I don't actually understand what this is
doing here so what is what are the x y&z
here oh x y&z are actual I see that's do
this apply this gate if and and where
I'm now confused so if hash sign so
that's if your measurement result is
that you get your first eigen value for
you know qubit like the first qubit you
measured and the first eigen value for
the second qubit you measured then
perform a why gate on I have to say just
in terms of the representation of this
for example you know presumably the
measurement is represented as you know
wire 0 is in state
one it's that right but if you look at
measurements on their own measurements
can be utilized outside of the circuit
framework here as well okay so what is a
rep measurement return so you can so if
you just like press M or like that type
in M and enter you'll see you just get
that but if you were instead to have as
a second argument a quantum state you
wanted to measure so if you put that and
then after that first argument you put s
you
okay what on earth is all of that okay
it's that is that just showing me women
let's just show me the picture here know
what enough is that showing me um okay
what what's inside this thing that's so
that's your measurement result and if
you wanted to now if you put you can
look at properties of that so if you put
square brackets and then probability
distribution or like I think it's
probability distribution okay so that
gives you the different states that you
couldn't then these are the state
vectors you could have ended up in and
the probabilities were a second wait a
second waiting if they are state vectors
why are they not represented I mean just
having I mean what are those density
matrices or what what are those things
those are the state vectors not the
Quantum's discrete states those are the
state vectors I say if you said instead
of probability distribution if you said
collapse then it would create a quantum
state out of those probabilities that
seems like a rather unfortunate word I
mean it should be like collapsed state
or something like that okay is that a
right I mean when we say collapsed state
I guess that's the right thing I hate
this stuff I don't really believe in it
anyway let never mind that the I mean I
thought this was the best way to see you
save all the measurement information and
then you can decide which what type of
thing you want I don't know I liked it I
liked it but I think I mean this is and
the operation we can't represent this as
quantum discrete operation just saying I
mean we're sure we
make measurement be one of these
operations I'm absolutely sure they're
fundamentally different well I
understand that but they're returning
these are returning quantum discrete
states whereas this is returning
see this is returning what is that what
is the head of that thing okay so it's
returning itself there because really
what that's doing so a quantum discrete
op okay
quantum discrete state
acted on by a quantum operation see
what's a little bit funky here is that
normally you have a quantum discrete
state which can be acted on by a quantum
discreet operation right here you're
saying you have a quantum discreet
measurement which returns a quantum
discreet measurement rather than a
quantum discreet measured state or
something okay I can I can definitely
change that well but I mean what's the
right way to think about this I mean so
the problem is if you say returning a
quantum measured state then that means
you've already collapsed it down which
is not necessarily correct because you
could want to get out the probabilities
of certain things happening like that
like we have right here sorry I'm sorry
what me through that again for a second
so the measurement you know you could
for your calculations when you're
observing things or whatever you could
want to have the information about the
probabilities with which things occurred
and this is the exact probabilities not
just you know running this a couple
hundred times and getting you know
problem
I understand I understand but I mean
it's oh wait a second so that the issue
that I'm making here is I understand
that
I I don't understand quite why you're
making I mean you say quantum discreet
operation normally those are information
preserving quantum operations like a you
know how to mod gate or whatever right
why is it so horrendous so each one of
those quantum discrete operations Maps a
quantum discrete state so quantum
measurement is you know in the simplest
case it is a projection which is not but
it which is not reversible
I understand but but the thing that you
get out is yeah
walk me through though this is saying
these complete state vectors have these
particular probabilities right whereas
previously we instead that these state
vectors have up here for example I see
yeah right that's right oh my gosh this
design stuff always force this one to
actually understand what's going on with
okay so see what's a little weird here
is that in the other case we've got a
state vector for a quantum discreet
state we've got a particular state
vector represented by one of these
sparse arrays so now we've got a
collection of possible state vectors
corresponding to the sort of eigenstates
the measurement of some whatever Walmart
that are that have assigned by the way I
would not call it probability
distribution it is not a problem at a
distribution okay probabilities put
plural okay or something or state
probabilities or something like that
because probability distribution I I
think well okay so where does anybody
know a kadek the categorical
distribution in the probability
framework this thing is really a bit
actually the correct thing for this
route to return will be some kind of
categorical distribution
does that make sense to you because
because what it's doing is just like we
have normal distribution or we have
personal distribution for example okay
so normally what's really nice is that
we can say Poisson distribution um let's
say we could say Poisson distribution of
six and then we can say PDF of Poisson
distribution of six comma X right what
that is what on earth is that what is
that thing I can't see that well I don't
know what it is but it must be something
that's come up from your oh we've
probably set you you were using single
letter variable names and that's what it
was okay there we go that's a more
reasonable pass on PDF okay X was just
set to something in the session right
right okay but my point is that if you
are able to return this is very cute if
you're able to return an actual
probability distribution right you can
go to town using all the standard
probability computation stuff okay fine
that's that's that I was I was
forgetting the name um right so
empirical distribution is yeah that's
reasonable enough for data values occur
with these weights right get what I'm
saying so in fact where data value D so
it's it's the flip around of these
things right um I don't think this is
quite right I think it has to be
categorical distribution because these
these are data values which are real
valued things whereas these a whole big
matrix thingies um and I think there's
something that is coming that is called
categorical distribution
maybe we can try to find that out let's
see who did I hear about that from but
neural network team yes that it was in a
meeting I would check with it in what's
the status of there okay okay fine cuz
that's gonna be needed here um okay so
one last go-around of this quantum
measurement thing so what you're saying
is um okay somebody is asking from our
livestream swoosh car is asking we're
just three states shouldn't it be a
power of two
the answer to that is this measuring a a
spin one object to what this particular
thing here what we did
95 what was line 95
what is s
state of those three things what's the
answer to why there are only three what
why there
three outcomes here
Jacob perhaps those are the only ones
which I'm not you know there's one not
zero here
did we lose Jacob and a sign of Jacob
hello hello yeah sorry I just had mute
on for a second um so even even if
you're dealing with qubits um you have
powers of two you could end up with
States when you project into to a
certain basis you could end up with
certain ones of your States go it's the
same thing oh I say okay all right I
understand but so the labeling of these
states by these fossils
yeah go ahead certain it's it's being
you broke up same thing what though yep
you just broke up um could you say again
so basically by virtue of
eight that we had
we can't hear you
please pretty the action though we can't
hear you properly breaking up
you hear me oh you missed yep can now so
basically the quantum states when you're
when you project them they end up in the
same thing yeah okay I get that all
right fine
okay so again quantum measurement
quantum discrete measurement what you're
saying is you need to get out from that
gosh I mean you've got to basically say
quantum discrete measured state don't
you I mean I don't really see a way to
get around that okay I'm anybody got any
other suggestions I mean the other
possibility I suppose the contents of a
quantum measured discrete measured state
what is what are its contents and how do
they compare to a quantum discrete state
or could we do something where we
basically say in here you know where we
where we have also a quantum discrete
state now we just have an indication of
whether it's a pure state Oram or a
mixed state no a measured state a
measured state it can be represented as
a mixed state is that true any pure C
can be represented as a mixed state no
but a measured after a measurement you
have a mixed state correct i yes well
you will have a pure state it's just
that you have a probability distribution
of different ones if you perform the
measurement and you forego all or you
completely lose all information about
what the measurement outcome was then
you end up in an image and a mixture
yeah I understand okay but but but okay
actually so what's up along with even
the distribution of possible
probabilities and their corresponding
States
well that's what this is here yeah
exactly yeah so me and a tree
measurement will be choosing one of
those which is the collapse to collapse
yeah and the collapse is inherently what
happens when you have measurement inside
of the quantum circuit when certain when
you say collapse how is it deciding
which of those to choose with some
random probability oh gosh yes that's a
horrible name yeah this would be one of
our runs on something okay that takes a
probability and returns I think that's
what I'm actually using I'm using random
choice yeah well so is this um can you
feed that that association to random
choice is it the round version of that
to random choice yeah well I wonder
whether it's the same way round it is
may not be just random choice except
associations I think that I just
manipulated such an I get the weights
and the okay but we should probably have
something that's consistent because we
have a notion of weighted data so maybe
we should return I mean I think the
thing we have to return no look if what
we fundamentally return is a categorical
distribution then all of these
operations will just work on it right
random variate will work random choice
whatever it is will work on it
okay what other information other than
these probabilities what other
information comes out of a quantum
measurement or is that it that's it well
do you want to have the measured value
and this final state yes so that in the
the quantum circuit you have actually I
think that there's an option for
forgiving the value as well I forgot
what it is but in the quantum circuit
you actually implicitly need to know
which value is measured and it does that
for you yeah okay but so that means we
can't just return some categorical
distribution we have to return a whole
structure that represents the result of
a measurement right yeah okay so this is
I mean it is some kind of quantum
discrete measured State is that is that
the right name for it I mean in in what
an earth does it mean okay so this is
now showing my I mean what is the what
is the correct version of quantum non
discrete measured state that is you just
found the position of the particle in
the box or something there is a notion
of a quantum measured state that is with
respect you know with Delta function
with some basis that's some Delta
function or something it's that right
yeah and in what sense how does that um
you know how does that how does that
relate to what we're doing here by the
way somebody on the livestream points
out this should be random variate um
they're absolutely correct um go ahead I
think a pair here which is the the
measured value and the new state without
needing so the output of this random
something would be a pair a bit like arc
mean and the sort of thing
my man augment doesn't return a pair
Agron returns one thing
you mean minimized or something returns
a pair yes yes I don't know which one it
is what are you actually proposing here
you're proposing that quantum if imagine
some sort of random measure that takes
the either day this state and the
operator or the probability distribution
and then it returns a pair which is the
measured value and state the new state
of the system it has to have their world
random somewhere but we don't want I
mean this random variate thing is a
funky you know tentacle here because
that's really just for show the random
variate thing what we really want to be
doing is representing the whole bubble
it's a distribution which we can then do
other operations all as it has in this
picture um listen what else did we need
to achieve in this in this meeting I we
still have more stuff to go over
but but okay um all right well fine so
we've we've got a path forward on the
graphics for circuits we don't have a
particular path forward on the graphics
for States so for now well I guess we
have to keep just returning them as
these explicit expressions um let me see
we've got a lot of these different
access ORS I think it's time to start
writing documentation pages for our main
functions okay um I can start doing that
okay do you know how to do it or the
okay um let me see I mean you've got a
bunch of other functions in here that
okay so some of these are just testing
functions what is quantum discreet
observable so that's an object that
encodes the thing that you want to
basically the basis you want to measure
it but it could be it doesn't have to be
just a basis in that it can also be a
POV M like a projection a positive
operator valued measurement and the
observable was like one way to talk
about all that stuff well but so that's
essentially one of the arguments to
quantum discrete measurement is that
right yes and if you don't use that then
it just assumes that you're measuring in
the identity in the you know the trivial
basis but but wait a second but is there
any other use of quantum observable
outside of the discrete measurement
function I mean no because all you do
with observables is you measure them um
well okay so then then we probably don't
want to introduce a separate whole
creature to represent this observables
what what we have to can we pack the
observable into the second argument of
or some argument of quantum discreet
measurement we absolutely can I was just
using this at this point for for ease
for my own cases okay I can definitely
pack that in well what would what's the
specification of is observable I don't
100% remember it should be stated there
to the hermitian matrix desk so it's
some hermitian matrix some yes so where
is that um right so if you then it just
assumes that you have the intensity so
what you're saying is that that in this
quantum discreet measurement you're
asking for these two quantum entities
measure them with respect to this
quantum state that right and then I
don't quite understand what does it mean
what does it mean to measure them it
measures them using this as some kind of
basis is that right so it measures so
you measure the observable in the basis
that is like implicitly given by the
observable is the hermitian matrix
really the observables described by the
hermitian matrix and what are the rows
and columns of the motion matrix
represent they're they're basically the
basis okay and where in this
representation in this form where are
the bases being input what are you
measuring it with respect to I mean it's
like spit out lets us pin down but where
where am I saying that right so if you
don't specify what the hermitian matrix
is then it just automatically uses the
identity so it measures it just you know
the way that you measure in the
computational basis right but so it
measures that but I still understand
this quantum discretes I see I see so
the basis then is literally the actual
rows and columns of that quantum
discreet States state vector right yeah
okay so the point is that you can give a
hermitian matrix that scrambles up those
how does it how does it get applied is
it like a similarity transform to that
state vector or something or what
it's something like that yes yeah okay
so that can perfectly well be a third
argument to quantum discrete measurement
seems to me I mean that seems like a so
this is what would would it usually be
called what would that hermitian matrix
be called yeah that give me know what is
it called in the world of I mean so
there is an observable but that
observable it's just the way that we
talked about is this thing the operator
corresponding to the observable it's
there I see I see I see I see I see
right right right right right that is
the operator that you are measuring I
see and so this is this function this
thing here is okay these are the okay so
let's write this out so these are the
entities that you're measuring these are
this is the basis and that's the
operator is that right yes is that order
of arguments right yes seems wrong to me
I mean I understand it's right for what
you've done but it seems like this is
like measuring you know when you say
expectation which by the way is
something that will work on our
categorical distribution you are you're
saying I mean okay so what this is
asking it's the expectation of an
operator in a thing distributed a
certain way I mean in a sense the analog
of this right if we wrote this here what
we would naively oh my gosh what a mess
okay that was a bad idea
expectation of Expo with X distributed
according to distribution right okay so
the analog of that in the quantum
measurement case would be you know
quantum discrete measurement of I would
think the operator
with the entities hmm am I getting this
right or is this is this the right
analog here I'm not necessarily pushing
this particular form but you understand
what the the question is what's the
analog so this is an expectation I mean
let me give the you know an actual
example here the expectation of x
squared with x distributed according to
a Poisson distribution yeah you're right
that is the end well let's walk this
through for a second because that
operator is simply a hermitian matrix
right so would it be this like with the
expression instead of being the operator
with that be the state sure I think I
think it would be the operator acting on
the state probably I'm not sure Jose or
anybody else do you can you see what the
answer is here I think this is correct
so the operator is the equivalent of the
expression and the state is what is
defining the probability distribution
what I'm saying what I'm saying basis
here I should say state I think so yeah
okay so interesting does it I mean just
for my understanding this distributed
according to thing so when we say a
state so quantum discreet what is the
relationship between quantum discreet
state and a classical distribution
answer one is dealing with quantum
amplitudes and one is some dealing with
one is dealing with classical
probabilities and so to say distributed
according to what is the quantum
probability analog of distributed
according to I think the amplitudes will
be here the best answer there fair
enough
but what we're having to say here okay
so the state encodes names of quantum
entities and this is saying entities
distributed according to this this
quantum discrete state right it's
integral and is a system is in a given
state that's equivalent of something
follows a given distribution we want to
measure all of the components of that
system you may only want to measure a
few of the components right so so the
better best form of this would be the
description of this would be okay so
let's write the description measures the
operator measures operator for you know
for the entities for the for the for the
entities in the state is that the right
way to said yeah and then we can have an
alighted form of this in which we drop
the operator at the front which assumes
it's the identity operator yeah that
looks good to me okay by the way
swish car from our live stream says
Bloch sphere graphics for each qubit
will be nice as well so that that's nice
and yes we can do that for qubits but in
general we're dealing with Indy over two
systems here in this package and you
cannot visualize higher dimensional
systems on any Bloch sphere whatsoever
wait a minute a Bloch sphere represents
the a single electron spin is that right
right and so so like you have a picture
that has a bunch of things with the the
spins pointing up and down and so on
right yeah you got you have some
position at some radius from the center
of your sphere and you know it's um
you know angular accommodation like some
fine beta that's like your phase and
amplitude but you can't do that for
spinning T over two systems or D is you
know greater than one
you know it's my mind my favorite
examples of silliness in the world is
you know the plaque on pioneer whatever
it was ten or something which has that
representation of the hyperfine
transition of hydrogen okay which which
I guess is a block sphere like
representation right but it's got spin
up spin down you know what I'm saying
mhm
um the um I mean that yeah so that that
by the way I mean what a well okay let
me just let me just take that
I just want to put this in our state's
representation thing down here I mean
that is a pretty stupid in in in the in
the space of things understood by aliens
the representation of spinors by vectors
is one of the most questionable things
one can imagine in my view but but that
is that is that right that's like the
Bloch sphere representation of these
things so not quite because on a block
sphere it's not just what orientation is
fitting and it's also not just up or
down you could have like it could be
pointing in any direction on the sphere
and it could also not just be at a
constant radius because if you have a
mixed state then it could be at any
radius but so so but what is it a
representation of it's a representation
of a single electron the density matrix
for a single electron is that right
right okay and you claim there is no
generalization of that for higher qued
it's exactly why is that obvious if you
can think about a way to represent all
that information then that would be
great but I mean oh did we just reinvent
a Bloch sphere like thing with this so
that's for multiple qubits that's not a
higher dimensional system no no I
understand that I understand that but
I'm saying yeah okay all right well okay
but that is clearly another useful
representation which we should be able
to have for quantum discrete state right
you can presumably we should be able to
say block blocks blocks sphere graphics
reasonable yeah and then that will work
for a single state song as it's been a
half mm-hmm with a density matrix and so
on right um all right listen I think we
are converging here I think we're
actually getting to the end of this
whole design discussion um I'm pretty
happy with what we're seeing here and
there's going to be pretty nice I mean
being able to get these categorical
distributions out that you can then
apply other operations to and random
variates and so on that's gonna be nice
we don't have to worry about I don't
think this quantum plot thing is
particularly useful okay that we may
want various access ORS that represent
things in different ways like this block
sphere like like some you know polar
plot or something of these and I think
that's what we should concentrate on is
taking the I mean this is basically
taking the quantum discrete state and
you know just one of the access ORS for
it should represent it there should be
various accesses that represented in
various graphical forms that sounds good
there
okay um okay to end our to end our
meeting here we have a nice quote from
the live stream from Michael Hale your
quantum stuff he says helps helps him
understand things but then onward to
games with general AI
genetically-engineered exotic pets a
molecular design so those are our so I
don't know that the the the molecular
design is probably closely connected the
genetically engineered exotic pets with
quantum with quantum microtubules in
their brains no doubt gets actually I
just for one second here I just want to
ask the question the quantum neural Nets
do we have any idea what that is yet so
I did some more research into that and
it seems like there there's really no
good way yet in the literature to do
back propagation on in a quantum neural
network you can do things like a quantum
hopfield network you know a single layer
like completely associated memory
system but if we want to do research on
our own I can try to you know look into
it how did you you know well let's just
think okay just for one second just
because we're on a roll here let's just
think about this just for a second okay
so so what you're saying is I mean the
the sort of the hopfield network thing
is just a matrix that just says take
this set of weights and apply a matrix
to them and then do that repeatedly
okay so apply a matrix to a bunch of
weights is something that so long as
that matrix is unitary kind of happens
rather naturally in these quantum
systems is that correct yeah okay so the
problem is you know the brain is not
going to I mean it's very tough to have
an attractor which is what you typically
need in a neural network when you have a
qua unitary transformation going on all
the time if I'm not I mean so what you
have to project at some point you have
to do a projection because otherwise
you're never going to have an attractor
because it's a you know it's preserving
well okay so this is like you know from
a dynamics point of view it's like the
there are these the Henin hile system I
think is an example of this these two to
two maps that are volume preserving okay
those are those are things which will be
like these unitary transformations that
preserve volume and don't don't have you
know I mean normally in a neuron that
it's highly irreversible it's going from
a large number of input States you know
here are all possible images but you
have to simply decide are they cats or
dogs right mm-hm and clearly that's not
what's happening in the quantum case in
the quantum case it's preserving all the
information until the very moment of
measurement right right okay so the
issue then is how do you I mean how do
you back propagate from a measurement
being literature has an answer to it so
let's think about that just for a second
before I go off and and okay how would
we think about back propagating from a
measurement so hmm so in a sense the
measurement I mean given a certain
amplitude at the end yeah I don't see
why that's actually so hard because when
a measurement happens it's projecting
you know you take the amplitude in your
projection in various ways and you get
the probabilities for the measurement
what you need is something where like
let's say you you're getting a cats vs.
dogs neuron that let's think for a
second well it doesn't seem so
impossible to me because there's some
precursor to that measurement no I'm not
sure reminds me of this older question
of whether there is chaos in quantum
mechanics and what's the quantum version
of aquatic system in classical mechanics
right so I mean what happened in the
quantum chaos business what did happen I
mean people like like our friend Michael
berry did all of those things with with
you know solving the Schrodinger
equation in a stadium and stuff like
this right this is where we need Michael
taught because he knows this stuff but I
think what happened in that case yeah it
was it was very different I mean it
ended up being sort of chaos with
respect to um solution to the you know
eigenvalues of the Schrodinger equation
rather than dynamical chaos I think even
though I mean in the in those billiard
systems right the classical you know you
have billiards bouncing around a stadium
right and what happened was there were
certain caustics effectively Sur which
correspond to the classical paths and
then
rest of the sort of quantum stuff was
filled in around that but I don't know
yeah okay well alright so that's the nub
of the problem then is how to do how to
think about how to think about back
propagation I mean because what you
ultimately want to be able to do is I
see you want to be able to adjust the
weights and the energy matrix which is
by the way a weird operation in its own
right because how do you do how do you
even imagine I mean you don't imagine
that you can do that quantum
mechanically do you you imagine that
that has to be something you know
changing the unitary matrix you get what
I'm saying I mean it's the code versus
data thing you're trying to change the
essentially the you know the circuit as
you have it right now is a fixed circuit
right it's not like something where you
are where you can rewrite the program so
to speak I mean this is the analog of
obviously a boolean functions as
compared to Turing machines and I
suppose then there's the whole quantum
cellular automaton thing which has never
really seemed to me to get very far I
mean it's just you have yeah I mean
that's by the way by the way by the way
by the way that is something we should
understand since we are in that business
okay given a boolean function what is
the you know some very small subset of
boolean functions can be thought of as
quantum quantum compatible boolean
functions yes those are the reversible
boolean functions yeah and so if I just
give you an arbitrary boolean function
so if I say you know given a boolean
function um
then I've got to go here but but given
given a boolean function some small
subset are reversible right um and we
can enumerate you know some particular
numbered boolean function is going to be
reversible how do I take that random
boolean function and turn it into one of
your quantum circuits right so even for
non boolean functions there actually is
a
methodology for doing it in but you have
to do measurements at the end of course
tube you know to do the non-reversible
aspect of it but it essentially comes
down to tricks with control knots and
toppling gates allowing you to do things
like XOR which can be used as type you
can do XOR with this you not and you can
end up doing and you know very trivial
and operation so what you're telling me
is that we should be able to have a
compiler right and that's something that
I've talked to Caesar and Jose about
fine fine do I mean so that that's then
that's nice so that's a compiler for so
if we do that we should also be able to
compile solid automata which are the
same deal basically um although there
you end up with these two to two
cellular automatons on I have to go it's
it's okay we're making good progress um
and um oh gosh people are asking all
these questions here this is what we a
cloud service for cloud deploy of
quantum circuit right yes that's what we
want to do what we want to be able to
have if anybody actually ever has a
quantum computer we want to be able to
take our quantum circuit description and
simply upload it to the quantum computer
and have it be executed that's the goal
right and okay so so somebody here is
saying back propagation is overrated
which I do tend to agree with um and
yeah okay so some videos asking what
about hierarchical temporal networks HTM
um anybody know enough about about Jeff
Hawkins as stuff to be able to comment
on whether that has a better quantum
analog well
one group of people here um all right
okay well to be continued
bye to everybody on the livestream bye
to everybody on the meeting bye bye